اعتبرها مستوى عالي بسبب بسيط جدا وهل
بسيط هذا هو اساسي الثقافه العربيه يعني
من اهم
انتاجاتها الثقافيه الشعر
والفنون والاداب كلها قائمه على النص يعني
حتى نكاد احنا من باب المبالغه طبعا هذا
وليس حقيقه طبعا لانه نقول انه كل فروع
الادب من الشعر لكن الاغنيه تقوم على
الشعر ايضا حتى التمثيل سواء المسرح شعري
او حتى كتابه شعريه حتى في الدراما طبعا
يعني او حتى دراما الاذاعيه او تلفزيونيه
ذاق الشعريه اعتقد انها هي الصمام الامان
في المجتمعات العربيه
وهي دائما النقطه او المفتاح الاساسي
عندما يتلقون الاغنيه يبحثون او يركزون
على النص
فيما بعد حسب خبرات الشخص الفرديه
قد يعني يتذوق اللحن صوت الاداء الالات
الامور الاخرى التقنيه ايضا لكن الشعر
العربي ما زال حتى الان واعتقد انه
فترات صعبه عليه الا انه ما خان المجتمع
العربي نهائيا